hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast live in targeted therapies for
cancer and autoimmune diseases I'm
Brenda Kelly Kim of lab roots and
helping the moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
miles and sponsored by roche molecular
diagnostics headquartered in Pleasanton
California roche molecular diagnostics
is a business area of roche diagnostics
it develops manufactures and supplies a
wide array of her native medical
diagnostic products services tests
platforms and technologies with its
broad portfolio of oncology neurology
microbiology blood screening tests I'm
these clients include researchers
physicians patients hospitals
laboratories and forth banks around the
world business was founded in the early
1990s found in the eye position of the
revolutionary Nobel prize-winning
polymerase chain reaction technology PCR
quickly replicates a specific fragment
of DNA or RNA two quantities sufficient
for accurate laboratory analysis for
more information please visit life
sciences Roche com we have a few
announcements before we begin this
webcast is designed to be an interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions like typing them in Q&A box
which can be found by poking in green
Q&A button if a lower left of the
presentation window will try to get to
as many of the questions as we can you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon from the lower right
hand corner of the slide window if you
have any problems hearing or seeing this
presentation properly please let us know
by clicking on the support button the
top right of your presentation Linda or
submit the problem for the green Q&A
button or left this presentation has
been approved for continuing educational
credits if you want to obtain your
credits please click on the get your
free cme c ii credits button located
lower left of your screen this will take
you to a page listing all of our
speakers and presentations please select
the cee cee any button under the
presentation and follow the instructions
to claim your certificate will now like
to introduce today's speaker dr. Philip
flow dr. Philip loam is the director of
the purdue university center for drug
discovery and the ralphs equally
distinguished professor of chemistry dr.
Lowe has spent over thirty nine years
exploring novel methods the drug
targeting and characterizing structure
function and pathologies with new roof
recite membrane has published more than
350 scientific articles and has more
than 50 US patents pending when more
information about dr. Lowe please click
on his name to see his background and
experience will now turn it over to dr.
Lowe for his presentation
an autoimmune disease is seeing you and
we take a unique approach to trying to
achieve the two major objectives that
are prescribed by the FDA for any new
drug new drugs need to be both safe and
also effective and the standard method
for trying to achieve both safety and
efficacy in a drug is to try to build
both properties into the same molecule
this is often very difficult as when one
optimizes the specificity of a drug for
a particular target or pathway one must
at the same time change the potency of
the drug and sometimes it's very
difficult to build both high potency and
high specificity into the same molecule
our approach is to build the safety and
the specificity into two different parts
of the molecule and that's shown on this
slide here where we use a targeting
ligand that is marked here in yellow and
we'll talk about a number of these that
are capable of carrying attached cargoes
either to cancer cells or sites of
inflammation and autoimmune disease or
infectious diseases and also we then
build a second part the potency up into
the payload shown in the upper left-hand
corner there the payload then can be a
therapeutic agent for treatment of a
disease it can be an imaging agent for
monitoring progress to therapy for
identifying patients for aid in surgery
is all described in just a moment and
then as part of the same conjugate we
also use a spacer linker connecting the
targeting ligand to the payload and this
spacer linker can be used to optimize
the PK the PD of the drug to a
also build in multiple drugs into the
same conjugate and exploit other
opportunities similar to this I'm going
to begin by using our first targeting
ligand that we developed folic acid as
an example and take you through a few of
the interesting applications of this
both in delivering therapeutic and
imaging agents folic acid as you can see
here is taken into cells by three
different routes on the left-hand side
we find that there are two transporters
are carried in the vitamin one is a
reduced folate carrier the reduced
folate carrier is found in virtually all
cells of the body another is a proton
coupled folate transporter it is also
found in virtually all cells of the body
these have lower affinity for the
vitamin in the neighborhood of ten to
the minus fifth moulder a third pathway
for uptake of this vitamin is a folate
receptor this receptor is very rarely
expressed as I'll show in the next slide
and this this expression is primarily
limited to cells that want to take up
the vitamin when there's very little
vitamin available as a consequence the
binding constant as a neighbor is in the
neighborhood of ten to the minus tenth
molar now the important application of
this information for the seminar today
is that the reduced voli carrier and
proton co folate transporters are found
throughout the body in all normal cells
and the receptors primarily found on
malignant cells and also activated
macrophages and I'll describe these the
applications of this unique expression
pattern in a moment this a slide if I
don't see the video running its supposed
to show receptor-mediated endocytosis of
the
of the appellate linked rhodamine
conjugate where the arrow points if the
movie were operative it would show
endocytosis of a Foley rhodamine
conjugate as it imagine eighths of the
cell surface and enters the cell cancer
cells take in that have Foley receptors
and take in folate conjugates x receptor
mediated endocytosis very rapidly the
internalization process takes just a few
minutes and the receptor eventually
recycles back to the cell surface for
more vitamin folate conjugates entered
by the same pathway activated
macrophages that also express folate
receptors actually Reese I take the
conjugates in also very rapidly but the
recycling rate is much faster only a few
minutes is require required before the
receptor returns to the cell surface
following entry into the cell the Foley
conjugates traffic through a variety of
endosomes and these endosomes are
generally reducing in nature and so
disulfide bonds built into the drug
molecules as you can see the the drug
mimic up above contains a disulfide bond
these disulfide bonds are reduced are
cleaved upon entry into the cells but
they're generally quite stable during
circulation and because our collate
conjugates reach their sites of action
in tumors or in inflamed tissues within
five minutes and saturate the receptors
within the same amount of time the
disulfide bond turns out to be
sufficiently stable in circulation that
we don't see much drug release but
following endocytosis into the target
cell the reducing environment releases
the drug you can see in this particular
image the red spots in the center show
that the released rhodamine that's
connected to folate by the disulfide
bond is trapped in endosomes if this
rhodamine were remembering permeable it
would diffuse out of these into zones
and enter the cell where are fully
receptor is accessible to parentally
administered folate conjugates turns out
that cancer a number of cancer tissues
but not all cancer tissues overexpress a
Foley receptor is fine primarily found
in cancers of the ovary lung breast
kidney endometrial colon and the amount
of fighting cancers as i mentioned
earlier also activated macrophages have
accessible for what receptors activated
monocytes do also but curiously resting
or classic macrophages and monocytes do
not express the folate receptor so this
receptor is uniquely found on only the
inflamed subpopulation of these
myelocytic cells then finally as will
point out in a moment the bully receptor
is expressed and accessible on the
apical surface of the proximal tubules
cells of the kidney and I won't go into
this any further but I will mention at
this point that we have tested a number
of very toxic folate link drugs in both
preclinical and in human clinical trials
and we do not find that any of them
cause any toxicity to the kidneys and
the reason why it emerged in a study
that we did a few years ago where we
followed the itinerary of these Foley
conjugates in kidneys and live mice and
we find that although the receptor
mediates uptake of the folate conjugate
by the kidney it also mediates
transcytosis of the folate conjugate
across a kidney where it's released back
into the bloodstream so it turns out to
really be a salvage receptor to keep the
patient from going full a division so it
captures the folate in the urine and
puts it back in the bloodstream to keep
you from losing the vitamin that you
need as a consequence the kidney doesn't
retain at nor is it nor is it damaged by
the lake conjugates
this bar graph shows the expression
level is these are some of our latest
data on fully receptor in different
cancers you can see that ovarian cancer
over eighty eight percent of ovarian
cancers express the folate receptor
about eighty percent of non-small-cell
lung cancers maybe three-quarters of
kidney cancers large number of
endometrial colorectal and breasts but
then at the same time you'll notice that
there are quite a number of very
important cancers like brain cancers
prostate cancers pancreatic cancers and
so forth that do not express such a
significant levels of fully receptor and
because of that it's we'll talk about in
a moment it is important to be able to
design targeting ligands that will carry
attached therapeutic and imaging agents
to these other cancers also and we have
undertaken this task on in addition to
the using pulling this light here shows
the image the distribution of Foley
receptors by imaging and on the left
hand side is a healthy patient in an is
healthy patient you can see in the whole
body scan uptake only in the kidneys and
if you remember a moment ago I told you
there were three sites where fully
receptors were overexpressed one was in
cancer tissues well this healthy
individual doesn't have cancer so we
wouldn't see any update there a second
was in activated macrophages and active
activated monocytes but not in resting
amount of what excels of any sort and so
because there's no inflammation in this
individual we don't see update had any
other sites associated with inflammation
and then finally we mentioned that there
was up taken me there were four late
receptors on the apical surfaces of the
proximal tubules cells and that leads to
uptake in the kidneys and as I said that
will eventually disappear as it moves
the follow the folate conjugate or the
vitamin back into the bloodstream on the
right hand side of this paired image
you'll see
a patient with stage three ovarian
cancer you can see them what malignant
disease throughout the peritoneal cavity
over on the right and the insert you see
the breast cancer metastasized to the
brain look below that you'll see a
primary brain tuner and so forth so in
patients that don't have cancer or
inflammatory disease you see just the
kidneys and other patients you'll see
whatever either the inflamed
inflammatory disease or the malignant
disease so this imaging we think is very
important as you'll see in this cartoon
I incorrect diagnosis of the real
problem can lead to an incorrect therapy
for that problem here the therapy that's
being prescribed as a mild sedative for
anxiety and vicodin for the back pain
and obviously that's not the solution to
the problem so a better diagnostics can
significantly assist in better than
tripping and designing better therapies
one of the Diagnostics that we have
designed is the use of these targeting
ligands to deliver attached fluorescent
light bulbs very selectively to tumor
tissues and this allows us to light up
tuners where the bright fluorescent
signal and using a fluorescent my
present camera this can enable the
surgeon to locate and resect malignant
disease much more efficiently and
accurately than was previously possible
we can also use this same structure for
delivery of photodynamic therapy agents
and a few other applications this can be
used as I mentioned above went with any
targeting ligand and I'll give you a few
examples of this now in the next few
slides this particular movie here
actually is a video of the provided by
go van damme and Vasilisa thias christos
at the university of groningen in munich
and what it shows is the first as far as
we know page surgery performed on this
planet using a tumor targeted
fluorescent dye and in this case the
patient was in jet
been about two hours before surgery with
fully linked to flourishing that's shown
on the left is not very bright they're
at and the Foley flourishing of course /
fuses throughout the body and is
captured by cancer cells at this point
of the surgery the surgeons dr. bad Dan
believes he's removed most of it
virtually all of the cancer that he can
see with the naked eye and now you can
see looking at the omentum of this
cancer patient they're looking around to
see if there's any additional disease
and they can't fight it until they turn
on the fluorescent lamp here they see
all these fluorescent lesions but at
this point in the surgery they don't
know if these fluorescent spots are
indeed malignant or not and so dr. Van
Dam has the technician take these with
her forceps and run to the pathologist
next door who then looks and evaluates
whether those fluorescent lesions are
indeed malignant or not and it turned
out from these surgeries and subsequent
ones performed by this group in Leiden
excuse me in greeting and that
essentially all of the fluorescent
lesions were malignant and they found as
you can see at the bottom of this slide
and with the citation where the data are
published that they were able to remove
approximately five times more malignant
lesions with the aid of fluorescence
than by standard methods in following a
group of I think eight surgeries this
next slide shows that in fact even very
small lesions can be revealed by this
method if the University of Leiden
Medical Center dr. bar Meyer and tumors
and hoops tins have been doing similar
work and you can see in this stain the
folate receptor positive tumor cells in
this section and you'll notice over on
the right-hand side where the
fluorescent folate fluorescein
accumulated following intravenous
injection and
in the arm even though this comes from
an ovarian cancer patient and the
lesions obviously from the peritoneal
cavity and you'll see that every spot
seen in the center panel is fluorescent
in the right-hand panel suggesting even
in that lesion up in the upper left-hand
corner of the panel there are only about
four or five cells there that even very
few cells can be targeted and
illuminated by this method will go on to
the next slide here and these data were
provided by dr. sunil singh hall at the
University of Pennsylvania who has done
quite a number of these surgeries on
lung cancer patients and you can see on
the left-hand side the image that is
visualized by the surgeon if you turn on
the fluorescent lamp you see the one on
the right hand side the major Legion
there in the center thats fluorescent
was was in fact seen in the CT scan the
smaller one on the lower right was not
and of course this changes the whole
diagnosis staging and so forth of the
patient and it also alters the surgery
of course this allows the surgeon to
remove these extra lesions that were not
seen and would not have been seen
without fluorescence more recently
because flora seen is not visible very
for more than a half a millimeter in
tissue we've gone and made similar fully
targeted near-infrared dyes that are
fluorescent in the near infrared range
where light is more permeable or
penetrating to tissue and the structure
shown here on the left on the right
comparison of the green versus the red
curve shows that the the full light
near-infrared died binds with the same
affinity as free folic acids that we
haven't lost any any affinity for Foley
receptors on cancer cells and here is a
surgery that was performed by the same
group at the University of Leiden
University Medical Center and that the
fluorescence is very diffuse there as
you can see it looks very
spread out and as a consequence that
indicated that there may be a
fluorescent lesion deep in the tissue
and that the light is being scattered as
it is as it comes out of the tissue and
eventually we're taking down they found
this fluorescent lesion which turned out
to be malignant which would have never
been seen by any other method this next
image just shows the comparison on the
lower right with seen by a surgeon using
all of today's standard methods versus
the image on the upper left which is an
image revealing what the surgeon sees
with these new tutor targeted
fluorescent dyes that are accumulate
only in malignant tissue and reveal
wherever malignant disease is located
you can see when they see that
fluorescent signal then they can go in
and feel it with their finger to see if
it if it demonstrates the altered tech
tile sensations that would are
associated with a more rigid tumor and
as you can see then if they are they
feel comfortable about it being go ahead
and pull it out and reset and this of
course turned out to be cancer we have a
lot of other movies like this but I'll
just jump to a few of the bottom lines
and that is very small lymph nodes as
you can see up the upper right and and
lower right can be revealed even when
they're buried using these near-infrared
dies and we believe in the long term
this can save a lot of lives by allowing
the surgeon to find all of the are most
of the malignant disease that may have
otherwise been missed moving on we
recognizing that this is a new
technology that could revolutionize
surgery in the future by allowing all
malignant disease to be quickly located
and resected we have gone on and linked
our near infrared die up to a number of
other targeting ligands in this
particular animal model we made a
targeting ligand for prostate specific
membrane and
this will allow imaging prostate cancer
we have another one that targets
cholecystokinin 2 receptor this images
and GI tract cancers we've got still a
another one that image is narrow kind
and one receptor is targets a number of
neuroendocrine tumors I could go on and
on and on but we have quite a few we're
trying to select the right collection of
these to put into a cocktail that we
believe will be effective for imaging
virtually all cancers in addition to
helping the search and find cancer
tissue we've also undertaken that hope
that surgeon avoid accidentally cutting
important healthy tissues in this
particular image i challenge you to
locate the the ureter and you can see
what looks like a number of different
tubes on the left up going up the
left-hand side and a little bit more to
the right going straight up and down and
even more than that but if you really
want to know you can use a ureter
targeted die and when you look you see
the ureters actually way over on the
right and this is important because
there are over a half a million
surgeries for endometriosis a year in
the United States and a clipping the
ureter can account can occur it's not
uncommon during those surgeries also
during colon cancer surgeries and
there's a often mistakenly clipped
because it's very very hard to see
another another potential application of
this of course targeting nerves and you
know avoidance of cutting nerves can be
very important in a number of surgeries
for example in prostate cancer surgery
the nerve nerve that innervates the
prostate gland is cut then the patient
is often incontinent and or impotent and
that's that
is important to avoid so this slide just
lists a number of the possible uses of
this these tumor targeted Flores advised
we've found we can use them to
quantitate circulating tumor cells we
can localize and resect the surgeons can
localize and resect more malignant
disease as I showed you elimination of
positive margins on the tumors is very
important so that there's no residual
disease left in the patient we committed
these tools can also be used for
pre-surgical endoscopic diagnosis of the
stage of the cancer and assessing
whether surgery is even and even called
for in particular cases if it's if the
cancer spread wide leave and often the
surgeon will decide not to operate but
just turn the patient over before
chemotherapy assessment of disease
recurrence it's for example in ovarian
cancer a patient goes through surgery is
then placed on chemotherapy and shortly
afterwards then the patient is placed on
chemotherapy and then there's a waiting
period and if recurrence does occur it's
only seen usually about 13 months later
if there were a way of assessing that
recurrence much earlier i think a lot
more lives could be saved and that of
course as I mentioned earlier
identification of metastatic lymph nodes
is important and avoiding damage to
healthy tissues so there's a lot of
potential for this let's talk a little
bit about killing tumors by targeting
them with the same targeting ligands I
just mentioned I'll give one example on
this this is the structure of a direct
identified a company that I found it has
taken into clinical trials it's in phase
three and you can see here the structure
involves on the Left folic acid in black
linked via a spacer in blue to a
cleavable bond that ties all but I spoke
about earlier in green and then the
warhead is this vinca alkaloid that is
about a thousand times more potent than
been blasting it's a modified version
event
it was taken into animal studies and we
can see that regardless of how large the
tuners are even up to eight hundred
cubic millimeters as soon as they're
treated the tumors disappeared the real
question was though with this very
potent drug which was very toxic and
dropped immediately from clinical trials
due to toxicity in its non-targeted form
that is when it was just administered
without a targeting like in the real
question that we wanted to answer
immediately was what happens when we
targeted to be still suffer from this
intolerable toxicity and you can see
after the first 100 patients were
examined with this folic targeted
version there were absolutely no great
for toxicities there were very few great
three toxicities and those are limited
to constipation and the associated
abdominal pain which can could be
treated with an over-the-counter
laxative this would visit these are the
results of the study with just a single
agent administered by itself but anyway
the prediction that targeting the drug
would reduce off-target toxicity was
fulfilled and demonstrated in this study
just to illustrate this further we saw
known you absolutely zero neutropenia no
bone marrow suppression even though the
naked drugs or something very similar to
it shows that and virtually half of the
patients the drugs also at the Foley is
also used to select patients in this top
example of a CT scan on the left and
then I fully targeted imaging agent lets
a technician based imaging agent linked
to folic acid you can see to the two
lesions very clearly and in that case
you had this would indicate that the
malignant lesions have folate receptors
and so if we can target a fully tanked
imaging agent we should be able to
target a bullet linked therapeutic agent
and we go ahead and treat that patient
in this example below the malignant
lesion circled in yellow do not show up
in the folate scan
middle and so the conclusion there is
not to treat and we'll follow through
with this and this just shows what
happens in and why this pre selection of
patients with the imaging agent is so
important here is a study with our that
folate vinca alkaloid only as a single
agent no accompanying cytotoxic drug and
we just looked at the survival of
patients we're a hundred percent of the
lesions that's the top a kaplan-meier
curve we're a hundred percent of the
lesions express the folate receptor and
when they're treated with a full eight
receptor targeted drug they do very well
in the middle kaplan-meier plot there
somewhere between ten and ninety percent
of the lesions in the patients were
folate receptor positive and they did
not do as well and then in patients
where none of Allegiance or folate
receptor positive they did even even
worse this just demonstrates the
importance of using an imaging agent for
selecting patients for therapy this is
also confirmed in studies of non-small
cell lung cancer patients again those
with higher percentages of folate
receptor expression did much better in
both overall survival and
progression-free survival whoops um I
don't know what happened there I'm there
I need some help I I not sure what
happened let me see okay it looks like i
have control over things again although
i can't see a lot of what i used to see
these are data on a non small cell lung
cancer patients using the same drug
where we're comparing the standard of
care which is docetaxel alone versus
docetaxel plus the folate targeted vinca
alkaloid called ec145 and you can see
just from the kaplan-meier curve that
the combination therapy led to a median
overall sir
vival of 12.5 months whereas the
standard of care docetaxel led only to
six point six months more recently we
have replaced the folate targeted vinca
alkaloid with a full a target of tubulin
and looking at these four graphs here
the folic targeted tibu licen b is in
blue and you can see that in all of
these different tumor xenograft models
the folate targeted to beYOU licen is
much more potent than the full a
targeted vinca alkaloid and actually
performs better for two reasons number
one it's fundamentally much more potent
as a basic drug and number two as you
can see here on the right in tumor cells
are in tumor xenografts that have been
selected for their high expression of
p-glycoprotein or drug resistant pumps
the fully targeted to beYOU licen is a
much poorer substrate of these pumps
than many other drugs and so it's
resistant to these e flux plums and so
that in addition to its higher potency
it's reduced susceptibility to eat
floods pumping makes it a better drug
this is now in Phase one clinical trials
and it's just in the dose escalation
stage what about fully negative cancers
on this is the crystal structure of
prostate specific membrane antigen when
this crystal structure came out we
immediately designed a small molecule to
fit into the bottom of that pocket that
you see at pockets about 20 angstroms
deep it makes great raw material for
structure-based drug design this is a
cutaway view of that pocket and on the
left-hand side you can see the drug
sitting deep in the pocket and there's
there's a spacer we have some additions
on to that spacer to improve overall
affinity and then on the right you can
see the therapeutic warhead or imaging
agent and we have used this to image
cancer
patience here is a comparison of the
same patient at the same time scanned
with a bone scan on are actually set
consecutively with a bone scan on the
right the bone scan is designed to pick
up raw bone where the cancer which often
metastasizes to the bone has eaten
through and exposed raw hydroxyapatite
and you can see late lesions in the
upper left hinge shoulder there and in
the ribs and so forth on the left hand
side is the image with the PSM a
targeted imaging agent that we designed
you can see the same lesions that you
can see on the right but many additional
lesions and these additional lesions are
due to malignant disease that is not yet
eaten through and exposed the raw
hydroxyapatite this turns out to be very
important especially in cases as you see
right here where you can see the
prostate gland which is malignant that
shone pointed at by the arrows there but
also a metastatic lymph node which would
never be revealed by the bone scan
because there's no bone there and so by
being able to image soft malignant
tissue this is very important of course
we can use this also to deliver
therapeutic drugs this structure shows
visit the structure of folate excuse me
this dupas we call it targeted to hbu
lies in conjugate and down below are the
data on tumor growth in animal models
the green curve shows that when we dos
these animals after their tumors reach
roughly 400 cubic millimeters they
immediately disappear this dupa
conjugate is also in phase 1 clinical
trials right now submit further on the
graduate student in my lab designed this
we have tart as I mentioned earlier
targeting targeting lying in the targets
call assist a kind of two receptor these
are the cancers that can over express it
you can see here the binding constant
and it's compact
addition and the image there shows the
uptake very selectively in the tumor in
this slide we can see the tarc the
structure of the therapeutic conjugate
of the same targeting ligand this also
leads to a good tumor control without
any weight loss as you can look at the
weight loss curve on the right and the
tumor control is on the left on the
neuro clean and one receptor ligands
also been used for therapeutic
applications so this is an imaging agent
on the left on the right is competition
and when we add a competitive ligand to
block receptors we see no uptake in the
tumor the structure of the targeted
therapeutic agent which is a tubulin
conjugate is shown on the top there and
again we get good tumor control without
any weight loss with this conjugate we
have a number of other ligands under
development for tumor targeting in our
lab and this just shows a list of some
of the tumors that we have ligands for
that we're developing right now for
clinical translation I just spend just a
couple of seconds on our use of these of
other targeting ligands for addressing
infectious diseases the same general
concept of using a targeting ligand to
deliver and attached imaging or
therapeutic agent specifically to sites
of infection is also valid this is an
image of some mice where we placed some
h1n1 virus three microliters on the nose
of the mouse and then waited three days
on the left and then injected in the
tail vein a ligand that targets the
virus infected cells on the right is a
control mouse injected with the same
imaging agent and it's a technetium 99
imaging agent and you can see that we
get targeting to the infected cells in
the lung and more
recently we've been working on a drug
for treating malaria we're actually
starting clinical trials on this the
anti-malarial agent blocks the egress or
the escape of the malaria parasite from
the red blood cell by inhibiting a red
blood cell enzyme that the parasite pets
has to activate in order to get out of a
cell and by blocking this red cell
enzyme rather than targeting a
plasmodium falciparum enzyme we believe
that we can prevent any mutation
generated resistance because the
parasite can't mutate the gemba genome
and it relies on this enzyme to get out
and so by blocking at weak and rapid
we're starting clinical trials with done
preclinical work in Vietnam we're
starting clinical trials very soon in
both Vietnam and Africa plainly for the
last few moments of my talk would like
to just address the application of this
technology for treating autoimmune and
inflammatory diseases briefly while
imaging cancer patients with our folic
targeted radio imaging agent ec 20 and
with image probably over a thousand of
these patients by now we noticed in a
few of them some uptake of the folate
targeted drug in the knee or in a
shoulder and we knew that a patient does
not get cancer the knee very often so we
wondered what might be happening here to
make a long story short we obtain some
synovial fluid from one of these
patients and look to see what cells in
the synovial fluid might have fully
receptors and we found that activated
macrophages expressed folic receptors
further pursuit of this research area
revealed that resting macrophages do not
express photoreceptors nor do t cells B
cells mast cells he is
you know Phil's basophils and so on and
so forth it's over unique property of
the very activated subset of monocytes
and macrophages and because these are
found in virtually all malignant alts
gives me all inflammatory and autoimmune
diseases this gave us a wonderful agent
for targeting inflammatory and
autoimmune disease I'll just show you a
few stains using a monoclonal antibody
to folate receptor beta it's a beta
isoform and these are human tissues
these data were obtained at Mayo Clinic
here on rheumatoid arthritis the brown
stain shows the expression of folate
receptor on these activated macrophages
that that was a the previous slide with
rheumatoid arthritis is this ulcerative
colitis you can see a lot of brown spots
those are collections of macrophages
this is scleroderma again it's
characterized by accumulation of folate
receptor beta positive macrophages
idiopathic pulmonary fibrosis this isn't
characterized by accumulation of these
anti inflammatory or alternatively
activated macrophages but still they
have folate receptors whereas resting
macrophages do not Steve Oliver at NYU
at the time you find now at Novartis
stains psoriatic tissue for us in the
upper right hand corner you see the
green spots reveal where macrophages are
located in the psoriatic lesions the
upper left you can see the stain for
polly receptor beta virtually a hundred
percent of the macro pages they're in in
the inflamed tissue is expressed Foley
receptors on the lower left you see
where cells are located and you can see
based on the hurks dye which state
nuclei and you can see again the blue
spots in the upper left hand corner
revealed that there are skin cells there
but the skin that part of the skin is
normal it's not sorry addict so it
doesn't have any macrophages or any
bullet receptors so imaging of
autoimmune diseases we can also use the
imaging agent for those these are images
of rheumatoid arthritis hands these were
done at Mayo Clinic by Eric Madison here
Virginia crowds at Duke University look
at osteoarthritic joints and they were
we they reveal exactly the sites where
active inflammation is occurring here's
some sjogren's syndrome we can we can
see atherosclerosis this wood published
on this a number of times and we can see
a ischemic tissue where the macrophages
accumulate after the ischaemia in this
case is a scheming colitis just to make
a long story short we've looked at all
of these diseases on this list and all
of them are characterized by a
significant accumulation of these
activated folic receptor positive
macrophages this is a lot of biz allows
for both imaging and treatment of these
diseases let me just talk about a
therapy for them briefly we've looked at
the use of a full eight targeted em and
after and Emin operands a precursor of
methotrexate it's more potent than
methotrexate by quite a bit but it's
also more toxic and so we selected it
because we don't worry about the
toxicity because we have control over
where it goes and by targeting it to the
activated macrophages we don't have to
worry about the toxicity here we see ec
semi c 7 46 which is the Foley depa and
an operon conjugate it leads to
significant control of the rheumatoid
arthritis in this adjuvant induced
arthritis model and rats and if we block
the receptor where the line showing ec 7
46 plus competitors where we add an
excess of folic acid to block the
receptor we see no efficacy so it really
is receptor beauty two on the right is a
comparison with methotrexate it's not as
good and as the targeted a man doctrine
competition doesn't work very well
either and we can also look at
experimental autoimmune uveitis is
inflammation in the eye and just to make
a long story short the result is to say
in these are data from June loose group
at endo site and she can she sees at 746
prevents the uveitis and you can block
that therapeutic benefit by adding
excess folic acid and the histology will
demonstrate that on the Left would also
looked at a model of multiple sclerosis
it's called experimental autoimmune
encephalomyelitis in this case the
animal is vaccinated against myelin
basic protein and they develop an immune
response to their the brain and these
animals become immobilized they can't
move their legs and so forth and if you
treat them with the folate targeted am
an author and they recover and can run
around the cage this again shows some
data on that that's the same data as
you've seen before so I won't repeat it
and finally experimental pull a targeted
therapy for experimental inflammatory
bowel disease this is a these studies
were done in Aisle 10 knockout mice they
developed a el sort of colitis as seen
in the images there on the left and this
colitis can be greatly prevented by in
this genetic model by just treatment
with the pc 746 the folate targeted em
and altering my final topic I'd like to
bring up i think is one that is very
important for drug companies interested
in conducting a clinical trial for any
one of the mentioned autoimmune or
inflammatory diseases we've found that
using a fully targeted imaging agent we
can actually predict the outcome of any
therapy long before the clinical
manifestations show themselves
and this is an example here in this
slide we have induced rheumatoid
arthritis collagen-induced arthritis in
these mice and three days after
induction of the arthritis we imaged
with the Foley targeted imaging agent
and the animal treated with methotrexate
on the Left shows know what taken there
in there inflamed feet to the arthritic
feet the animal treated with
dexamethasone on the right shows an
Aleph take of the Foley targeted imaging
agent the animal in the center that
wasn't treated shows significant uptake
that's just due to the accumulation of
activated macrophages if you look on
this slide in the upper left-hand corner
the clinical score at this time and down
below the plot thickens for that time
shows absolutely no difference between
the treated and untreated animals that
is physically looking at at swelling of
the paw redness and all of the different
parameters associated with scoring the
rheumatoid arthritis they're
indistinguishable but if you follow
those same animals later on and by day
11 there are enormous differences
between them yet that was not visible at
83 when the imaging agent revealed it
now this is this suggests that you might
be able to use a pulley targeted imaging
agent to predict long before physical
symptoms emerge whether your drug is
working or not so you know just to see
if this might apply to other drugs we
looked at some biologics with the same
question in mind we looked at amberlynn
Orencia in the mouse model and after
three days both of them also knocked
down the inflammation in the feet as as
indicated by this full a targeted radium
imaging agent the disease control's in
shown in the center and it doesn't show
anything and again if you look at the
plots in this paper that I think just
appeared online is this Jets just
appeared online you can read about it
there's no indication at this early time
point you know even though later these
biologics both had an affair
Don at benefit in treating the
autoimmune disease we go on we decided
to look and see well maybe everything
shows up so we looked at a drug that
these that collagen-induced arthritis
and animals do not respond to him and
that's a naproxen and indeed we didn't
see a response and the clinical data
confirm that then finally we did well we
decided after that would go to a number
of different autoimmune and inflammatory
diseases to see if it it were the case
and this is another one ulcerative
colitis and you can see the healthy
animal on the left no uptake the
diseased animal in our ulcerative
colitis model shows significant uptake
and then when we treat that with just
standard drugs for treating ulcerative
colitis I met a Dean and sulfasalazine
we saw at four days right after starting
the treatment significant reduction in
uptake of the imaging agent even though
when you look at the clinical score at
this time point you can't see a
difference so again we pick up and can
predict the outcome long before it's
it's evident in the clinical examination
the same thing applies I'll just move
quickly since the time's running out for
a pulmonary fibrosis which is a disease
characterized by anti-inflammatory rm2
like macrophages and again the standard
therapies their work and the results can
predicted then we thought it might be
very important finally in these for use
in predicting outcome when the clinical
outcome would not be evident for months
and months and months and this would be
an advocate treatments for heart disease
to look at the build-up for example
atherosclerosis and this is we looked at
on the right valsartan rosiglitazone
round acrylic zetia flew past and so
forth and all of them showed what we see
under treatment very early a very
significant effect long before the
clinical differences were manifested
so just concluding I think there's some
oh I forgot I put in just a little bit
here on why not use large antibodies for
all of this it just turns out that I'll
just skip to the point that antibodies
penetrate tissues very very slowly it
takes several days for them to reach
their sites whereas small molecules
here's what here's a good curve showing
in the same animal in the same tumor the
penetration of a full a peg rhodamine
conjugates oh it's folic acid targeting
rhodamine but there's a large peg in
between and those are the first few dots
through the first 60 minutes there and
then at 60 minutes in the same animal we
add folate rhodamine with no peg in it
and immediately the tender saturates the
larger molecule simply doesn't penetrate
very fast and we find that to be a big
advantage for imaging so here are my
conclusions good drugs that go to the
wrong cells cuts cause toxicity so
targeting can overcome that nonspecific
drugs can be targeted to pathologic
cells with low molecular weight homing
my aunt's of the sort that we've
designed responding patients can be
selected with an imaging agent targeted
with the same ligand targeting or homing
ligands can be found from any diseases i
showed you can certainly showed you
infectious diseases they showed
autoimmune inflammatory diseases and
then of the additional applications can
be found that he's targeting ligands and
i spent a lot of time on the
fluorescence guided surgery but there
are a lot of others here's my lab the
group that has done all the work and I
give them all the credit because all I
did was sit in the office and answer
questions and then here are the names of
a lot of people i need to give credit to
they at other institutions that have
been very instrumental in the success of
this project so thank you very much for
your attention and i'm happy to answer
questions and i have a i'm not sure
where to get to this questions because
do i click on the question and answer
thank you doctor lower for that
informative presentation our audience
can submit their questions by clicking
on the human a botany which we have
found for green tuning button a lower
left of the presentation window but try
to get to as many as we can you do have
one question already if an issue which
is you normally but has more folate
receptor how can we know that it is
normal and well I think we have to rely
on the fact that most of the normal
tissues that express folate receptor
express this receptor in an inaccessible
location where it wouldn't be imaged
with a fully a targeted imaging agent
that is injected in the vein ferd let me
give an example of this there are fully
receptors on the apical surface of
alveolar epithelial cells in the lung
these receptors are only on the surface
of the cell facing the air sacs so
unless your blood bleeds into the air
sacs your full lately imaging agent will
not access those receptors and will not
bind to them so as you saw in the image
of the beginning a healthy individual
that has neither cancer nor an
autoimmune or inflammatory disease
should show up take only in the kidneys
in this particular case the folate
receptor is also expressed on the apical
surface of an epithelial cell but
because voids are small enough to filter
in the year into the year enter into the
filtrate they can access this receptor
on the apical surface which is the
surface facing the urine and so because
of that that is one yep ethereal surface
that has fully receptors that can be
accessed there are very few others
they're only in the lungs and then
there's one in the choroid plexus of the
brain is on the wrong side of the
blood-brain barrier but other than that
we shouldn't see any update so if you
see uptake it should be at a site other
than the kidneys it should be cancer or
an autoimmune or inflammatory lesion
any other quit any other face yes we do
have another question is the folate
receptor always targeted or can some
other receptors in targeted as well I'm
with folate we only see the folate
receptor targeted now there are foliot
receptors different isoforms one is
fully receptor out and that's the one
that's expressed on cancer cells and on
a few of these epithelial cells and I
mentioned folate receptor beta vitz
expressed on activated macrophages but
not resting after pages or other cells
there is also fully receptor Delta and
that's expressed on the open the egg and
it's also expressed on regulatory T
cells but it doesn't bind folic acid
with any with physiologic affinity at
the binding constant is three orders of
magnitude weaker than the others the
binding constant for alpha betas that we
don't target it it just doesn't have a
pion of affinity and we never see fully
receptor gamma so then we use other
ligands as i mentioned to target other
receptors we use dupa to target the
prostate specific membrane antigen
receptor and so forth so we've got
ligands for all sorts of different
diseases that target these diseases and
we are using them to deliver both
imaging and therapeutic agents okay okay
do you have time for one more question
dr. Lowell would writing ligon targeted
therapies did the studies evaluate the
ratio between a full a target imaging
and neutrophils segmentation I'm not
sure what what the questions about um
the Foley target the Foley targeted
images you know have varying degrees of
to her to background ratio or or for our
you know inflamed lesion the background
ratio it depends on the
abundance of the cancer cells or the
abundance of the activated macrophages
but where they are highly abundant the
tumor to background ratio is very high
and we don't see updated neutrophils i'm
not sure what the neutrophils
segmentation question is about
neutrophils do not have a functional
folate receptor okay it is all the time
we have for questions now I would select
our stuff below if he has any final
comments while audience oh if you have
other questions you can go ahead and the
email meet them to me I I'll try to
answer them although I get it over 100
emails a day of our time keeping up with
them but certainly if they're pressing
questions be happy to address them thank
you for your attention and if you have
any suggestions for good experiments I'd
love to have them thank you dr. Lowe I
would also like to thank our sponsor
today roche diagnostics as a global
leader in health care worst diagnostics
offers a broad portfolio of tools that
help healthcare providers in the early
detection prevention diagnosis and
treatment of diseases in molecular
diagnostics versus driven by a vision of
working with laboratories like yours to
improve the medical value you offer in
microbiology infectious diseases
oncology and genomics we continue to
meet unmet needs through our investment
in research innovation and scientific
excellence to learn more please visit us
Diagnostics da rocha